back here in europe eu leaders have
agreed to develop a covet 19 vaccine
passport
that could ease border crossings and
allow people more freedom to travel
again
eu leaders met for a virtual summit to
discuss coordination
they're already under pressure over a
lagging vaccine rollout
germany's chancellor says it will be at
least three months before a vaccine
passport system
is up and running with slow vaccinations
coronavirus variants border chaos
and summer holidays at risk there was no
shortage of talking points at this
virtual eu summit
during a four hour video call leaders
try to find a united way forward
in the fight against the pandemic the
pressure is intense concerns can't just
be waved aside with the eu
lagging behind on vaccination numbers
and new variants spreading rapidly
across the continent
the b-117 is by now
in all member states but one
the south african variant is in 14
member states and the brazilian variant
in seven so there's a lot of challenge
ahead of us
apart from ramping up vaccine
manufacturing and easing production
bottlenecks
the eu will put more energy into
detecting these more contagious and
dangerous mutations
through a dedicated program with spring
on its way
tourism has made it back to the agenda
greek prime minister kiriakos mitsutakis
was one of the first leaders to call for
an eu-wide vaccination certificate
in an attempt to ease travel
restrictions and save the summer holiday
season
that's something all leaders could get
behind but how and when exactly this
vaccine passport could be rolled out is
uncertain
we expect it to be done by summer i am
not a programmer
so i cannot make any guarantees like i
cannot guarantee vaccine deliveries
but the political requirements are to
reach this goal within the next few
months
but for the moment member states have
agreed that tourism
and all non-essential travel is not an
option
for more on this i'm now joined by our
brussels beer chief alexandra for now
and alexander
when will we see these passports
well presumably within the next three
months
that is what german chancellor angela
merkel said after the meeting but she
didn't want to commit to any specific
date because as she stressed
there are a lot of details that are
still being worked on
in berlin but also in brussels the
european commission would like to see an
eu-white certificate and if not
then they want to make sure that
national
vaccine certificates will be recognized
in every member state
but i think it's fair to say that what
we saw yesterday was real progress
compared to
all the discussions going on going on
for weeks now we have this broad
agreement that
vaccine certificates are coming
so when i have this passport in this
summer as the chancellor indicated
will i be able to travel the eu freely
like i used to
well that's of course the key question
but i don't have any answer for you yet
because that is something that the eu
leaders
did not agree on angela merkel said
that maxine's certificate doesn't
necessarily mean that you are allowed to
travel
french president macron was also a bit
skeptical saying that you know we
have to make sure that no one is going
to be discriminated against because we
don't have enough vaccines because
young people still have to wait to be
vaccinated
but i think that the pressure is is
really growing from
from different member states saying we
need to open up trouble we need to open
up
tourism the austrian chancellor
sebastian courts warned the european
union that
if they are not going to to to do it
together
austria will go it alone so to have this
passport to get this passport first you
have to get a vaccination
so what have you leaders said they want
to do about the embarrassingly slow
vaccine rollout well they said that uh
anything that is necessary has to be
done to speed up the
rollout to ramp up the production there
is a new task force that
has apparently be able been able to
identify a potential location that could
be used to ramp up the production
and ozola fondella and the head of the
european commission stressed during the
meeting that you know
trying to calm down i think everyone
that deliveries are increasing that we
are going to see
more vaccines arriving in the next
quarter but of course
eu leaders are under a lot of pressure
to
deliver progress to deliver results to
their populations and
they were also talking about a possible
complete
export ban for vaccines but
there was no a broad majority to to
introduce that because at the moment the
european
commission is just controlling who is
exporting vaccines out of the european
union but there is no
um export ban and that was not agreed
upon that
is going to be one in the future
i'm brussels beauchief alexander phenom
in there thank you alexandra
you